hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to tattletale now if
you notice by the eggs collected someone
said that it was very very important to
the story to get all the giftings so I
went back and I played through up until
this point again to try to make sure
that I get all of the eggs possible now
I wanted to talk about why this game is
scary and it is to me at least I'm not
gonna say this game is scary to
everybody but for me this game is
terrifying and I find that it's mostly
because it set up a lot of stuff given
that I played through it just again I
realized that it set up a lot of things
that didn't immediately happen it it
alluded to the possibility that they
were going to be scared there were
unsettlingly creepy things going on in
this game but it didn't get to it right
away it wasn't until the third night
then anything really scary actually
happened not even really scary scary
things happened but it wasn't until the
third night that something threatening
actually happened so I'm on the lookout
for even more eggs by the way 17:17 and
i miss up the way I could have missed
him I was so close I was so careful I
might have missed one I have no idea
I've been trying my best
hi okay cool I'm sorry did I interrupt
something
carry on your conversation whatever the
[ __ ] you're talking about
sure was super important grab
tattle-tale grip which one where the two
of you I can't even pick up the other
hello
holy [ __ ] don't yell at me my god I
wouldn't dream of it tonight for 30
second oh oh no oh no okay all right I'm
gonna stop being such a big baby
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] yeah okay all right
then we did it Wow oh boy oh oh I don't
know why I thought he'd be back here huh
I'm gonna get okay
at least I got an egg I might not have
gotten oh there we go egg number 13 so
I'm still on track I'm definitely on
track because I got up to 12 before
which meant that this one was the
correct one for this one so there's got
to be more eggs here and I want to find
them I definitely want to find them all
I don't know what the ending is but
someone said that it was incredibly
important that I find all the eggs then
again it might just be a red herring oh
I see you okay I see you oh you're
hiding so good let me tell you how good
you're hiding oh that's the cool time
shut up oh shut up
oh oh okay all right good you got your
treat man I'm gonna have to take care of
its needs while running away from oh
okay wow I sure did you wanna oh yeah
[Music]
yeah okay all right I'll give you a
treat God Hammer
I mean double checking for eggs oh boy
here Christmas lights on eggs 15 okay so
I'm getting better I just need to get
these guys my oh shut up
oh look I don't wanna but here you go
I don't know why I need human food Omega
T then
oh hi hello yeah
found you alright so we can play again
hahaha we're gonna die oh my god okay
in what bedroom in my momma's bedroom
your mama's bed god okay okay so the
moral the story is don't [ __ ] do that
cuz what did I do wrong
I mean a knock on Mama's door no my mama
and your mother are exactly the same
mama hey don't do that no no no no I
with you okay
not on that one oh I need to feed you
okay all right goody goody good Hey
I did need a groom my Furby oh boy oh
boy
girly to be losing my voice yeah yeah da
[ __ ] oh okay
alright fine it's fine it's fine oh boy
okay alright ow my neck is so under
loosely tense right now
okay so it's got to get through this
minute and a half is not that long I've
got nothing to worry about
everything is 100% fine got that P
meters goes down so quick all right I'm
fine I just need to stop being such a
little baby then I good oh [ __ ] me no
thank you
Oh [ __ ] finally oh yeah sure walk
I'll get you in a goddamn second oh oh
shut up
oh [ __ ] I get it oh [ __ ] man
all right oh man I can't believe I'm
already losing my voice Jesus what did i
do what did I do to deserve this
I don't know oh hi oh boy Oh should I
get the used bandage oh boy I've got 17
of 22 only five laps to go yeah I got
you alright
grab the VHS oh I'm sure that's I'm sure
that's good is it a ring style VHS and
also why is this so much ketchup down
here that doesn't make any sense at all
do you think feed off and ketchup
and any other egg any other eggs I can't
even wrap them back up in a in his box
Jesus I need to play this VHS in my
bedroom TV that sounds pretty good
really happy about that
I don't see any of their eggs and I got
em oh these ones were a bit scattered
but there were where he was every time I
took that self-explanatory cameras
you're gonna turn snap on me oh oh oh
what is that what is the dark
tattle-tale calm public 1022 98 why why
does why does a VHS have controls like
this that doesn't make any use that
doesn't make any sense
oh [ __ ] oh God
Oh No hi mama
oh hi mama don't look at me mama oh my
god oh no oh oh that a clickable no okay
all right okay hey storage
[Music]
Bonnie oh my god okay all right that's
another body set the body let the
[ __ ] body you can't fool me that's
the body that's literally a dead body
this is taking a nap which is entirely
possible I suppose
okay all right
wake up wake up wake up okay I'm ready
all right what do you got okay whatever
hi
wake up yeah we're having a party for my
mama come hop back and I think I what I
do that you're awfully conversational
you know you're not even conversational
in the way you were before you just have
a normal conversation you're talking to
me like a human would or a possessed
beautiful arm off me
why is the front door open the front
door open hi hello found you oh my god
my voice is completely on no sound act
number 19 collected 18 of 22 so I don't
think I miss one in the last one's gonna
hi I hope I did
oddly enough when I was playing I was
able to go through this I was able to
unlock this before like there was a way
if you went out for that egg that was on
the front porch you could go out here
and you could unlock it I thought that
was going to have an effect later on but
it may have just been training me for
the future
ah shoosh see shelter there we go number
18 so I am on track so all of the other
eggs are on this level this level alone
so I just kind of find all over the eggs
and everything's gonna be okay okay look
I got a present
should I open it probably not okay
hi all right then well I'm still shitty
brat a shitty Mimi brat that opened the
presents to do oh okay alright keep
telling yourself that alright I can't go
in the backyard
alright right knock on mom's door is
gonna end in death okay mom oh that's
the only way to the basement there's no
other way oh no oh no oh I gotta go in
this side basement oh by the way there
are pictures of his family so this kid
has a sibling and they're the parents
pregnant with the kid and then there's
pictures of Ken alright let's go
downstairs I'll see what happens okay I
think I got all the eggs of thing oh
there's nothing gonna do oh oh hi hi
how's it going oh good
oh great there any eggs for me okay
alright but I'm gonna do that
find a friend by the Christmas tree okay
oh that's how good all there's a good
oh yeah good good
mom's upset when mama so bad hi oh [ __ ]
okay I'm out of here
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
right up okay [ __ ] high whoa what the
[ __ ] how long have you been there okay
everything okay
what you think fine everything good
everything good okay I gotta get this
guy so I gotta bring another friend into
the fold I think that's what I'm
flipping
oh why is mother watching mommy
Wow okay okay
god damn it [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you piece
of [ __ ]
oh god damn it aah oh man god damn it
[ __ ] you dude oh no I'm not oh boy oh
boy where's the door
where did damn dog ha come on
[ __ ] I'm in big trouble
it's okay it's okay that's [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] [ __ ] come on what the [ __ ] she's
[ __ ] [ __ ] god damn it oh mama
doesn't hate me you don't know that
about mama oh maybe you do no mad about
mama maybe you know that about mama you
might know that about mama oh just shut
up and be good and then maybe mama ain't
gonna hate me no more oh boy that ain't
good alright bag I don't know where I am
I don't know where I'll [ __ ] why am i
over here oh god damn it oh this is
[ __ ] ain't it and good this ain't
good this ain't good oh [ __ ] dude
don't kill me please I like life I'm
just a kid why are you gonna kill me
maybe you're not maybe you're not but I
still can't help but think this is
probably gonna kill me if I don't get
this on the first go
[ __ ] no no no oh god no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh okay so okay
we're so good everything's okay
things okay things okay bad idea to be
in here I'm gonna get cornered I'm gonna
- the diamond a diamond to die on don't
pull me in the beginning
Oh another egg here in the bush
if the eggs shoosh shoosh is the
rabbit's foot if there's only two eggs
left
so I just got to go for it all right
everything's fine whoa okay I'll go the
long way around black no I won't what
[ __ ] [ __ ] Marvis camellia Hut
oh [ __ ] dude
my [ __ ] god dammit
Locke [ __ ] man ah okay everybody relax
it's totally fine now for some reason I
screamed my entire voice out I don't
know why I don't know how maybe because
this game terrifies me but I'm gonna
give myself a little bit of a breather
before I finish this game I've almost
got all the eggs I just have to be very
attentive of where they are and also I
have to be very attentive of where mama
is because mama is a problem and mama
hates me so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know how I'm doing
now in the comments below and if you
play this game or if you haven't played
this game yet try for yourself so thanks
again as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]